we've talked about the foundation which
is avoiding debt the third one i would
say is setting yourself up for wealth so
how are you going to make money i
already said earlier
that most millionaires
in order to
get to the first million dollars which
is probably the hardest to make you know
for being honest make a hundred thousand
dollars isn't that hard once you've made
a million dollars to make four million
dollars isn't that hard um it's
generally the first million that most
millionaires will agree is that is the
first and the hardest to make but once
you make it you're like oh that was no
big deal
right
so you want to set yourself up for
wealth again you've only got so many
years so many decades
in you
when does your time end who the hell
knows
you know maybe you're met with an
accident early on maybe you live you
know the ripe old age of 110 who knows
but what i'm saying is that you want to
you want to start early
there's way too many guys that spent the
better part of their 20s which are going
to be the best years of your life i mean
that's generally when you're healthiest
you're an adult you can pretty much do
anything you want i mean you know
you're no longer a child so you have the
rights of any adult out there
and you're young and healthy and you've
got
nothing in you but piss and vinegar
you're probably poor [ __ ] but you're
probably got loads of energy and lots of
opportunities ahead of you
so take it seriously you know like what
are you gonna do with yourself um don't
waste your time on dumb [ __ ] one of the
other points that i um
was going to make a note on actually
it's in there we can talk about college
university as a fourth point but
never letting
school get in the way of your education
knowing that it's probably going to take
you a decade to make
a million dollars acquire you know that
and assets
outside of your principal residence of
course that's that's generally the
definition of a millionaire by the way
is is is having assets uh in excess of a
million dollars outside of your
principal residence
hopefully that's that's clear
but set yourself up in your 20s man
seriously like why would you wait to
your 30s or 40s
why would you spend your 20s chasing
girls or sitting around playing video
games doing nothing with your life right
um
what do you what are you doing with
yourself in your 20s you should be
asking yourself i mean if you're a 23
year old watching this right now and
going um yeah i don't really have a plan
what are you going to do are you going
to go get a stem degree are you going to
be a scientist an engineer a doctor or a
lawyer an accountant somebody that needs
some sort of degree okay cool go to
school and do that
let's move on talking to
talking about school
but
if you think that spending two three or
five years on a business accounting
degree with a
that doesn't actually like like an admin
sort of piece of paper that doesn't give
you an official designation that lets
you work in accounting firm um something
like that my favorite is the business
and entrepreneurship um you know degrees
because
family
is very
influential in most people's lives
and why wouldn't they be right
but
there's old world order thinking infused
in family because they're older than you
they live decades before you right could
be your parents could be you know um
aunt uncle grandfather grandmother
whoever whoever it happens to be
old world thinking is
go to school
uh finish high school and then get a
post-secondary education and something
that you can use for your life that's
going to be a useful skill
some people take stupid [ __ ] like basket
weaving uh
feminist studies uh
you know whatever underwater basket
weaving feminist studies
um there's a lot of people that spend a
good deal of time and money on that [ __ ]
and
they make great coffees for me at the
coffee shop awesome coffees i i love
drinking my liberal coffees they taste
very good
um
i feel sorry for the amount of debt that
they have and the useless degree that
they have but they you know it tastes
good
let's be honest
so you got to understand i mean if
you're going to go to school
are you doing it because your family's
trying to cram it down your throat and
saying this is what you need to do and
go get this business degree or this
entrepreneur's degree i can tell you
something you're not going to learn [ __ ]
from somebody lecturing you on how to be
an entrepreneur in school
you can take that 20 30 50 000
on tuition and books and residency
everything that you're going to spend
over those few years
and you'd be actually better off taking
that money and trying to start up a
business it'll probably fail right
almost guaranteed it's probably going to
fail
but you're going to learn a lot more by
trying to start up your own business
that way
these
these professors
with the rare exception of some
world-class
entrepreneurs that are probably doing
lectures at harvard or something like
that the vast majority of these
professors have never done anything with
their lives they've never started up a
business they've never had an exit
they've never solved problems they don't
put a dent in the universe you know in a
business world like i've like i've
eliminated close to a billion dollars
worth of unsecured canadian debt and i
fixed a lot of people credit uh credit
ratings as a result of what we did with
tdf in the years that i was running the
company um
i asked myself you know if i'm going to
listen to you your advice on
business or
running your own business small business
entrepreneurship whatever they have to
call the course have you done it
yourself do you have any experience in
that i have a course on that i have the
school of entrepreneurship it's got like
less than five hours worth of lectures
but it's distilled down to the bomb
material that you need to know
no fillers no time wasters none of that
[ __ ] blah blah blah 50 grand spent
honestly if if you want to learn how to
run a business and what it takes to be
an entrepreneur
rub your hands together and grab a
thousand bucks and get in that course in
august when i open it up you can just
get on the email list if you want to get
notified that way
or there's a waiting list it's been in
the top comment of all my videos but
i'll make more reference to it when that
logs but college university for the most
part
as a rule
don't do it unless you're
seeking a stem degree
scientist engineer
lawyer doctor you know something where
you need to qualify
uh to perform that professional service
and you'll get paid quite well you know
with one of those degrees um
they don't
most of the guys that have those degrees
that i know don't stick in that one area
for their entire life which is fine at
least you've
got a useful skill you've been certified
to perform that professional task
and you can perhaps use some of the
learnings from that and something else
if you decide to move in move out into
something else start up your own
business you know as a professional
there's any number of ways to do it
but college university generally
speaking is a total waste of time you're
better off taking that money trying to
start up a business and hopefully
you'll learn something out of that but
you're probably not gonna end up with a
business best case scenario
you end up with a multi-million dollar
business at 23 right
uh worst case scenario you know you
spend some money and it flops and you
learn a lesson but i guarantee you'll
learn more than what you will sit in a
classroom listen to some blah blah blah
blah blah hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you